what's up guys paddle season continues
out wisecrack so last month we piloted a
show called the film tourists it was on
the wolf of Wall Street we haven't seen
that one yet be sure to check it out
this is the second episode in that
series this one is on the shining before
we get to it this video is sponsored by
movie a curated online cinema streaming
exceptional films from around the globe
so you can get your 30-day free trial at
movie comm slash wisecrack and on with
the show
[Music]
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining or the
world's most persuasive argument for
taking the stairs this movie scares the
[ __ ] out of everyone but why
[Music]
it's hard to say what exactly is wrong
with this place is it haunted is it all
on their heads is it possessed by the
devil
Tony something about an Indian burial
ground whereas a lot of traditional
horror gives us an easy-to-understand
reason to [ __ ] our pants The Shining
deliberately avoids an easily
describable premise and this is part of
what makes it so damn horrifying it
deprives us of logical explanation
Kubrick accomplishes this in a variety
of ways but I'm here at the Overlook
Hotel to talk about one of the most
surprisingly simple perspective one of
the most effective ways to create a
strong sense of perspective is through
the way a shot is framed and sequenced
see a shot can be objective subjective
or fall somewhere in between purely
objective shots show us a scene as it is
a God's eye point of view as if we're
eavesdropping or watching a play
subjective angles directly insert us
into the action showing the view from
just beside or behind a character purely
subjective shots take us directly into
the eyes of a character usually by
showing their face first followed by
their visual perspective or emotional
experience it can also invite us to
question what we're seeing like an
unreliable narrator in literature in
this scene we see a shot of Danny's face
then a cut to the girls then Danny's
face again with this simple sequence of
shots we're being shown the events
through Danny's mind let's see how
Kubrick takes this basic principle
perspective to create an indescribable
supernatural feeling
considered the famous scene of Danny
riding his tricycle through the hotel's
winding corridors Danny give me some
skin using a state-of-the-art piece of
equipment for the time Kubrick is able
to achieve supernaturally smooth
movements to follow Danny showing us the
hotel from a child's point of view we
follow Danny in a traditional subjective
shot that emphasizes his experience
navigating a large maze like hotel but
we don't follow him perfectly watch how
the camera lingers after he's left frame
and then hurries to catch up with him
one film scholar calls this the
wandering camera because the camera
ambles along like its own sentient being
or here and imagined monster stalking
Danny through the halls this grates the
sense the hotel is alive and watching
Danny through his vacation when the
twins show up we move more intimately
into a subjective sequence of Danny's
POV flashing between his bloody visions
Danny covers his eyes looks again and
now they're gone so perhaps the girls
are just in his head by starting with
Danny's point of view as we follow him
but then shifting to a possible camera
monsters point of view and then back to
Danny's may be unreliable own vision the
film undermines our ability to interpret
the events in front of us whose point of
view is this Danny's the hotel some
demon now let's consider jack is all
this creepy stuff in his head - did
someone just spiked the water with LSD
in this otherwise normal hotel take the
scene in the apparently empty gold
ballroom in this scene we go from a
close-up of Jack as he seemingly
addresses an invisible being the reveal
shot of Lloyd this subjective sequencing
of shots could suggest that Jack is
hallucinating and just when we're sure
that this is all a subjective delusion
Kubrick moves the camera backward over
his shoulder
taking the shot from his direct point of
view to a more objective one
from there Kubrick gives the scene and
objective reality by showing both
characters and a shot together Lloyd -
the real deal we think until Wendy shows
up and the ballrooms suddenly empty and
were left totally confused and creeped
out so what's going on we don't know and
the camera work makes sure we'll never
find out now at times Jack's point of
view even seems to merge with that of
the imagined predator that was following
Danny in this shot Jack's view looking
down on the model hedge maze blends into
an aerial view of his family wandering
through the actual hedges this effect
happens again as he chases Danny
in the final scene see how the same kind
of shot that used to be stalking Danny
through the halls has now mingled with
Jack's point of view further confounding
the various supernatural elements of the
film we're not using point of view to
screw with reality Kubrick also uses our
perception of physical space to creep us
out how do you make a huge otherwise
normal hotel and present it as a
claustrophobic nightmare
Kubrick is famous for what is called
one-point perspective which adds to the
cramped feel with one point perspective
near perfect symmetry draws the
audience's eye to the one vanishing
point at the center of the frame giving
the sensation that we're being drawn
into the shot which is further enhanced
by the tracking shot in word it feels
uneasy like the walls are collapsing
inwards that's why even though the
Overlook Hotel seems like a spacious
setting we feel increasingly cramped as
the movie goes on almost like
claustrophobic reaction which can occur
when people are shut in together by
juxtaposing large spaces with much
smaller ones Kubrick is able to get the
viewer to feel really claustrophobic
this starts with the opening shot of the
mountain which cuts to the shot of the
family clown car style then we move from
the large sweeping hotel lobby to the
Torrance's small hotel quarters while
the hotel may be large the Torrance's
are trapped in increasingly smaller
spaces within it
homey eventually Jack ends up locked in
a fridge
Danny escapes through a tiny window and
nobody has any elbow room through these
tricks and perspectives stanley kubrick
is able to add a layer of creepiness
that if aids simple description and
that's why the shining is so great and
why film nerds will continue to talk
about it for years to come
there's so much more to talk about in
the shining so if you like this video
let us know if you want us to do another
and as always thanks for watching peace
alright guys hope you enjoyed that we
got a couple more coming out before the
end of the year so this episode is
brought to you by movie those of you
listen to our movie podcast you know the
movie has been gracious enough to
support us there as well and because of
them were able to continue making
episodes of the film tourism so movie is
a curated online cinema that focuses on
prestige films festival hits and beloved
classics there are always 30 perfectly
curated movies on the site every day
they present a new film and every day
they take one away movies a really great
way to discover international directors
you might not be exposed to otherwise
recently movie has been featuring the
works of Hong Kong filmmaker John Ito
who is famous for making really awesome
gangster films I watched the film triad
election in college and it catapulted my
love for Hong Kong cinema that movie is
playing now on movie along with other
Johnny toh films like mad detective and
vengeance so if you like gangster movies
you're gonna love Johnny toe and if you
like discovering new cinema
you're gonna love movie so try a movie
free for 30-days at movie comm slash
wisecrack that's mu bi comm slash
wisecrack for your extended free trial
thanks to movie for supporting us and as
always peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]